wir wollen jetzt darüber diskutieren wie
wir mit ungeimpften im land umgehen
werden gerade schon über die impfpflicht
diskutiert und erinnern uns an einen
wahlkampfauftritt von fdp chef
ist nicht frei von der dortmund
angekündigt soll ich jetzt um den pavés
kreiert werden die fdp kommt ihr denn
her wachsen hier sind sie mich darauf
muss und dass umgehend für nicht
diskriminiert ach ja
nicht der funktion des bv wesel fdp
meine meinung ist der gesellschaft wo so
viel geld kann der ungeimpfte sich
höchstens selbst bewerben deshalb sollen
auch im herbst ungeimpfte zb in die
gaststätte gehen können vielleicht wird
der voraussetzung eines negativen tests
den sie aber nicht bezahlen müssen das
macht die solidargemeinschaft sagen sie
jetzt sagen sie das auch noch nach den
wahlen das sage ich vor den war nach den
wahlen und 2007 haben sie gesehen dass
die fdp nach wien fahren sogar bereit
ist nein zu sagen zu einer regierung
wenn sie dann zu sagen brechen müsste
hätte das kam anders war das eine
wahlkampf lüge
naja das erste was wir gemacht haben ja
in der ampel ist der dänische lage von
nationaler tragweite zu beenden und
instrumentenkasten die die länder hatten
so zu beschränken dass es um wirksamkeit
geht natürlich hätte ich mir mehr
freiheiten gewünscht und hätte mir nicht
gewünscht dass eine del tabelle kommt
gar keine frage nichtsdestotrotz ich
glaube das was wir getan haben gerade im
dezember nach der bundestagswahl hat
sich wohltuend von dem unterschieden was
die große koalition insbesondere die
unionsgeführte bundesregierung ein jahr
zuvor getan hat auch ausgangssperren
lockdown aber teilweise ausschließen das
ist schon das ganze auftritt von
christian lindner also ganz viele haben
im wahlkampf ja auch gesagt wenn ich das
wissen wir einfach nicht wie das läuft
wie sich das weiter entwickelt das war
dann die omikron variante nicht die
delta variante herr dr und bei diesem
auftritt hat ihr parteichef aber ja ganz
konkret gemacht er hat gesagt mit einem
test wird man reinkommen als ungeimpfte
die geschichte ist aber mit dem test
kommt man nicht rein ins restaurant es
ist genau das gegenteil
jetzt wäre der novelle das ist richtig
während der del-tabelle war es eben
anders im dezember deswegen weil mein
hinweis da gerade vorhin aber nochmal
ist hat sich wohltuend von dem
unterschieden was wir von einem jahr
hatten und ich sag nur mal ein beispiel
deswegen zeigt das natürlich dass
politik dynamisch ist die cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion hatte bis vor wenigen
tagen auf ihrer website stehen auf die
frage wird es eine allgemeine
ich geben nein es wird keine allgemeine
impfpflicht geben bekanntermaßen ist
sogar die haltung des
fraktionsvorsitzenden eine ganz andere
das erzeugt natürlich diese lage ist
dynamisch aber zeigt noch einmal wie
schwer wir uns auch mit solchen
entscheidungen tun soll heißt hinein und
darum dass schon länger erhältlichen
gesagt einen solchen wahlkampf etwas
völlig anderes sagen kann als man dann
ein paar wochen danach macht ein paar
wochen ist das dynamisch wenn man
versprechen nicht einhält na ja
noch mal es war damals geprägt von einer
möglichen winter variante das war die
data variante insbesondere im dezember
und da haben wir das gemacht was ich
vorhin beschrieben haben was christian
wittmann die video angedeutet hat aus
dem sommer nämlich dass wir ungeimpften
zugang gewährt haben jetzt haben wir
eine andere situation bei omikron
deswegen hat sich die minister printen
konferenz auf das thema zweig plus
geeinigt was ich gut nachvollziehen kann
ja es ist eine dynamische lage ja da
muss man sich auch mal korrigieren aber
summa summarum haben wir eine gänzlich
andere pandemie bekämpfung als noch vor
einem jahr und eins bleibt natürlich
richtig das gilt auch für ungeimpfte das
impfen ist die beste bekämpfung gegen
gegen diese pandemie und deswegen kann
man nur allen dazu raten sich auch
impfen zu lassen kann man das vor
stimmte einfach so der virus variante
vor die füße kippen dass die variante
schuld ist wenn man im wahlkampf
versprechen abgibt und dass anschließend
nicht hält also die fdp hat ihre gesamte
oppositionspolitik in den letzten zwei
jahren zu einem großteil auch darauf
ausgerichtet gegen die impfpflicht zu
sein und auch gegen eine vielzahl an
freiheitseinschränkende maßnahmen in
diesem land zu sein jetzt zu sagen wir
sind für eine impfpflicht weil wir
gerade irgendeine variante haben dass
das ist nicht der punkt nein die frage
ob ich für oder gegen eine impfpflicht
bin ist eine frage meiner inneren
haltung dass es nicht eine frage des
infektionsgeschehen es dass es auch
nicht eine frage der auslastung der
intensivstation das ist nämlich die
frage wie viele tausend pfleger uns
verlassen haben im letzten jahr ja wie
die arbeitsbedingungen sind in den
krankenhäusern und so wo es diese frage
beantwortet wenn es gibt viele maßnahmen
dieses wie diesen virus zu begegnen
würden sie das wahlkampf lügen nein ich
würde ich würde es als das ende einer
tragischen geschichte sehen ich nehme
der fdp ab dass sie eine eine eine eine
glaubhafte auffassung in dieser sache
vertritt und zwar gegen die impfpflicht
schon immer war weil es eben in ihrer
dna
und sich eben jetzt aufgrund der
koalitions zwänge man möchte ja weiter
regieren möchte gut regieren und vor
allem ruhig und friedlich regieren sich
da hat einfach ein stück weit tag
deswegen frau schenken nach der lüge
weil herr holetschek ihr csu ex minister
andreas scheuer ja genau das gemacht hat
er hat diese lange nase dem christian
lindner gemalt er hat ihn den otto
genannt teilen sie das
ich spreche hier nicht für andreas
scheuer ich glaube dass man in einer
pandemie zu verschiedenen einschätzungen
kommen kann ich selber war am anfang
auch gegen eine impfpflicht ich will das
klipp und klar sagen weil ich nach wie
vor eigentlich der meinung bin man muss
mit argumenten die menschen überzeugen
ich glaube aber wir werden aus dieser
pandemie nur rauskommen wenn wir jetzt
diese impfpflicht egal in welcher
variante einführen und deswegen muss es
auch möglich sein dass man seine meinung
korrigiert und dass man auch dann
situationsbedingt sagt jetzt müssen wir
aber einen anderen weg gehen